salut après un an et demi de vidéos de
spectacles et d'écriture de livres j'ai
décidé de faire une pause cet été pour
me reposer oui mais aussi pour vous
préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en
septembre vous est demandé sur twitter
si vous vouliez quelques facteurs rapide
et divertissant en attendant alors
pendant ces 60 jours de pause je vous
laisse une vidéo rapide et sans
prétention tous les jours pairs à 11
heures on se retrouve à la rentrée et
tout de suite ça lui 12e vidéo de cet
été donc on est le 24 juillet et l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir pourquoi le
dr house s'appelle le docteur house
c'est intéressant si vous avez suivi un
peu la série il est clair que c'est un
détective du médical mais ça reste un
détective
c'est même comme ça que david shore a
vendu le projet à la fox en expliquant
que ce serait vraiment des enquêtes sauf
que les criminels se seraient des
microbes
parce que à la base cette série c'était
vraiment ce concept là ce n'était pas
encore porté par une personne n'avait
pas encore cette figure emblématique
deviendra dr house et quand ils
cherchent à construire le personnage
principal ils se disent on va s'inspirer
clairement du plus grand détective
sherlock holmes et c'est comme ça que
holmes devient house parce que sherlock
si tu enlèves le l200 nom de famille ça
fait home & home et house tu vois le
rapport c'est la maison tous les deux et
c'est dans la même mécanique que watson
devient wilson
voilà on est sur un petit fact cours je
vous ai fait une vidéo d'ailleurs de
pourquoi sherlock holmes eux s'appelait
comme ça si vous voulez la voir elle
existe toujours sur la chaîne et puis
c'est le principe de cet été des vidéos
courtes mais tous les deux jours comme
ça vous avez un petit peu de contenu
pour apprendre quelque chose vous
étonner de quelque chose et ça jusqu'au
30 août donc rendez-vous après demain et
n'oubliez pas de cliquer et de vous
abonner si c'est pas encore fait et ba
oui
profitons-en salut